moin Ich bin's euer Sydney herzlich
Willkommen zu Autobild das Magazin heute
haben wir eine echt coole Sendung für
euch es geht um Sportwagen um Tuning um
Luxusautos und natürlich wie in jeder
Sendung um Elektromobilität
das Duell Elektro gegen Benziner wir
testen den VW alibas vor Marktstart hat
er gegen den klassischen Multivan die
Nase vorn
es fühlt sich irgendwie sportlicher an
wenn du sonst als ein Bulli fährst du
sitzt halt wirklich oben auf und das ist
hier ganz anders also er ist wirklich
direkt davon vom lenken her
und der 700 PS starke Rolls-Royce Ghost
Hit oder Tuning
der Samthandschuh in dem der Rolls-Royce
sonst steckt der hat eine echt kräftige
Faust und 700 PS und 950 Newtonmeter
können meinem ordentlich in die
Magengrube fahren
und gleich zu Start haben wir richtig
einen raus der neue Porsche 718 Cayman
GT4 RS ich meine schnell ist er mit 315
Spitze aber der Sound Leute der Sound
ist irre also dreht die Boxen auf weil
unser Redakteur Jan Horn lässt es
richtig krachen um herauszufinden ob so
ein GT4 ist der beste
rennstreckenporsche aller Zeiten ist
[Musik]